Thanks, Sarah.
Now, I want to merge the coin branch and the master branch together.
After the merge, I'll want the master branch to update and
point to the merged version.
So if I didn't already have the master branch checked out,
I would check it out now.
I'll just verify.
And yes, I am on the master branch already.
I'll run git merge master coins to create a merged version of the two branches.
When I hit enter, my editor pops up so that I can type the commit message for
the merge commit.
Unlike the other commits, this one comes with a default commit message.
Merge branch coins.
I could change it if I want to.
But leaving it like this, makes it clear when I've merged two branches.
So I'll just leave it as is.
So git let's me know that it made the merge and the file gain.jf has changed.
If I run git log, I can see the merge commit.
Now I'll go ahead and test whether this worked.
If it did, I should see both color and coins when I run the code.
Well, I can see that there's color and there's a coin.
It looks like the merge worked correctly.
One thing you might notice though is that the coin is not colorful like
the rest of the game.
That makes sense.
Git only merges the little changes that you make.
And the code to add this coin added a non-colorful version.
Now if I run git log again, I can still see the merge commit and
I can see these commits added by me and Doug.
And there's also some commits by Sarah and
enter with the commits by me and Doug.
Since the commits are sorted by the time they were created.
Now this causes an interesting side effect on git diff.
Let's say, I wanted to view the difference between these two commits.
I could do it and I would see the difference between them, but
this commit is not the parent of this one.
So I wouldn't just see the changes introduced by this commit.
Let's try it out.
Now as you can see, there are quite a few changes in this diff.
But actually, this commit was pretty small.
To see just the changes introduced by this commit,
I'd have to diff it against it's parent.
But how do I know what the parent was?
While git includes a command called git show, which will show you what
changes were introduced by a commit compared to its parent.
So that way, I can see the diff between this commit and
its parent without actually knowing what the parent was.
And now there's a much smaller diff.
Since I don't need the coins branch anymore, I'll delete it using the command
git branch dash d coins, where d stands for delete.
This won't delete the commits in the branch, it will only delete the label.
That could have made the commits hard to find.
But those commits are now reachable from the master branch, so
it's not a problem.
Here you can see git let's me know that I deleted the branch.
To get some practice creating a merge commit, go ahead and
repeat my steps on your own computer if you haven't been following along.
If you're interested,
you can also introduce a new commit making the coin solid and yellow.
But this is optional since you weren't required to
have experience with JavaScript.
If you do want to make the corn solid and yellow, I recommend using git diff and
git show to see what code was introduced in both branches.
Otherwise, the solution video will contain instructions for
how to make this commit if you're curious.
Did you merge the branches on your own computer?
Select the most accurate option